merci beaucoup denis sommer on part tout
de suite dans le jura pour la deuxième
circonscription du jura retrouver la
députée sortante de l'est républicain
marie christine dalloz qui est donc
qualifié pour le second tour avec 29 17%
des voix et qu'elle fasse elle
et bien justement une candidate de la
république en marche
anne pro grosjean bonsoir madame dalloz
ça n'a pas été facile pour vous pour
vous qualifier ce soir
non c'était une campagne difficile mais
on l'avait compris
on le savait la machine médiatique avait
annoncé préalablement une un
raz-de-marée la république en marche
bon la réalité c'est que je suis devant
ce soir et les 8000 électrices et
électeurs qui se sont portés sur mon nom
est bien ont reconnu mon travail de
proximité mon engagement ma
disponibilité et surtout en implantation
locale
parce que moi je vis dans le haut-jura
j'habite dans le haut jura et je côtoie
au quotidien des eaux jurassien mais
marie christine dalloz est ce que vous
vous considérez en danger ce soir vous
avez à peine deux points d'avancé sur la
candidate de la république en marche 29%
des suffrages au premier tour il ya cinq
ans dans un contexte où le président de
la république était françois hollande
vous aviez réalisé 37% des suffrages
c'est beaucoup moins
est ce que vous êtes en danger ce soir
alors déjà il n'y avait pas le même
nombre de candidats premièrement
deuxièmement je n'ai pas souvenir que le
président de la république françois
hollande s'était adressé à tous les âges
toutes les électrices et tous les
électeurs en leur demandant de voter
pour sa candidate donc ça c'est une
grande différence
et puis le contexte médiatique était
beaucoup plus modérée on n'avait pas et
les sondeurs et les médias qui tous les
jours nous répétait qu'il y aurait plus
de 400 voire 4 120 députés
la république en marche crois que c'est
ça la différence mais le haut jura est
une terre de résistance et ma ce soir
mon score a prouvé que nous étions des
gens volontaires et résistants qui
reconnaissait une élue locale les luttes
proximité qui a fait son travail